The joe rogan experience.
In a perfect world,
where would you look all this to end?
I want the Walters.
Sounds crazy.
My dream is I'm going to free whales.
There's going to be a sanctuary.
I'm going to free marine lens whales.
I'm going to have a hand in this.
That's going to happen.
Number two,
do you really think that's going to happen?
You think they're going to enact legislation that makes them release those
animals?
I think so,
yes.
Really?
Yes.
What makes you so hopeful as two or three they rangelands tried to kill this
bill for years.
Now they've not been able to this time next week to set the sucker should go
that whale sanctuary sanctuary project.
They're going to build a whale sanctuary.
There's going to be a place for whales.
If it's in Canada and all the exportation laws are that marine land can't get
rid of their whales.
There will only be one place for whales if that business he likes to evolve or
if there's any type of ownership changes.
I see this being a big deal and to me how this sanctuary would work.
Well,
you'd have an environment where is a pen off in the ocean and you know it'd be,
I mean various different pens for various different procedures if you will,
but the idea is that if they can't be wholly released,
then you've got a place where they have a sense assemblance of,
of,
of freedom,
if you will,
but it'll be in human care.
There'll be more of like for instance,
a viewing platform where people be able to view the whales versus,
and how big of an area we talking about massive.
Yeah.
I can't say the square footage.
I don't know because they,
nothing's finalized yet.
So we're still in the development.
Would they develop a bay or something?
Would they would want to ideally get a bay that has good water change over that,
you know that that works.
If you can find that,
and I mean the east coast is looking really good these days.
Is there a model that they've drawn up?
Not Co.
There's models.
Yeah,
no,
absolutely.
There's good friends.
We look at something like this and if you look up the whale sanctuary project,
I'm sure you'll find tons of different columns.
I just don't know how they're keeping the ORC is in those things.
If you put a fence up,
they're not going to go anywhere.
They wouldn't jump the fence.
They don't,
there's something about jumping out.
I mean,
when the,
when the wild captures happen,
what do we got here?
There's the whale sanctuary.
We're building a model sanctuary where to whales and dolphins can re re
habilitated and live permanently in their natural environment.
So it's a step.
So this is a step between this and then the,
the wild.
Yes.
No.
Are they going to free them and then release fish in there for them to eat?
I imagine there'll be all of that every which way.
It would be nice too that allow them to actually hunt and kill the fish,
which I'm sure that's what they want to do.
The fact that they can feel the natural rhythms of the sea.
I mean,
they're in tune with the senior and their environment.
The pools,
no place to what it says here.
Um,
for medium survive four years,
median survival time,
uh,
in years for wild caught orchids at a marine park for years,
1000,
100 square yards of space and a large display tank.
And a typical high end marine tank,
314,600 is the minimum number of square yards for the first whale sanctuary
project.
Seaside sanctuary.
So this is 314,000,
600 square yards.
So it would be a massive place.
Hundred and five is the number of captive orchids and Belugas in North America.
So that includes marine lance of marine land has half the Balugas in North
America.
It's crazy.
And they fly under the radar because no one wants to talk about them.
Right?
24,
seven round the clock care care for the whales at the sanctuary.
That sounds beautiful.
Murraylands threatened to sue these people.
These people are fucking,
I am dude.
Me Buy more.
We need more than just you.
It seems like fuck man.
People listening.
Please get involved.
This is a a great step though.
I love this idea of this step,
you know,
like have something that's like a bridge between the captive and the wild.
Also,
it would allow their atrophied dorsal fins to,
to reinvigorate.
They can start diving deep again.
I mean,
you know how deep it necessarily,
but at least a little bit and get,
you could train these animals to physically take them for walks,
if you will.
I guess you'd call him swims where you would be able to leave and having them
just follow a boat and go for some extra.
So you can totally,
I mean the,
it really the,
the things that this is going to present the opportunities for these animals is
brilliant and amazing.
And the board is comprised of all your,
all your wild animal,
brilliant scientist.
I mean,
this is the project.
This is the future.
Yeah.